[Music]
I
be very honest with you when I do dr.
King and I'm performing is as if dr.
King takes over it's like the spirit of
dr. King comes into the room if you
listen to the majority of his speeches
right now
he's right in live with over dealing
with today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Stefan Ferguson I travel
across the world performing his the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. I am
the only person who is licensed by the
king of state to perform the works of
dr. King I used to be a DJ we took some
of dr. King's old records and as we were
mixing them in I began to emulate some
of dr. King's old records particularly I
have a dream a good friend of mine said
man you sound just like dr. Cain you
should really consider taking your work
to another level I realized that it was
a gift that God had given me to continue
the work and the legacy of dr. King and
free debris
from the prodigious hilltops of New
Hampshire let freedom ring I've been
performing as dr. King for about 15
years get a lot of requests to perform
in different areas from Madrid Spain
London England
I've been honoured to get recognition
from a lot of great people President
Barack Obama reached out to me I have a
letter thanking me for my work so that
was a very powerful recognition
I've even got that from King family
members
I speak for the entire family that we
know of no one who can actually sound
like my own children his cadence is
unique it has a slow southern drawl to
it but a sophistication at the same time
and Stefan just really flatters us off
with the way that he's able to bring my
own voice back to life
I believe it resonates with people
because we're living in a time that we
needed with all the hatred the divisive
mnestheus e in the world I think it
really inspires people to stand up to
speak out I may get to the age where
it's gonna be difficult but I'll still
be trying to do it
[Music]
you